ICONIC SEATTLE GUEST.
KEVIN: I HAVE GOT TO GO TO THE
SOURCE, THE ORIGINAL.
THAT IS BEAST MODE HIMSELF.
TAKE US THROUGH WITH WHAT YOU
THINK THE KRAKEN HAS TO DO TO
HIT A BEAST MODE LEVEL TO START
THE SEASON.
MARSHAWN: REALISTICALLY, I
BELIEVE THAT SINCE IT IS REALLY
A REAL PHYSICAL SPORT, THEY HAVE
TO GO OUT THERE AND PUT A REAL
PHYSICAL PRESENCE EARLY AND
OFTEN.
JUST TO SHOW THEM THE SEATTLE
STYLE OF PLAY.
I THINK THEY WOULD BE ALL RIGHT.
KEVIN: I FEEL YOUR.
THAT MAKES PERFECT SENSE TO ME.
I AM SURE TO FOLKS AT HOME.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, THE
SEATTLE KRAKEN SELECT, FROM THE
NASHVILLE PREDATORS.
TAKE IT AWAY.
MARSHAWN: THIS IS THE FIRST
PICK, RIGHT?
WITH THE FIRST PICK, WE ARE
GOING WITH THE BOY BOY, CALLE.
CALLE JARNKROK.
KEVIN: CALLE JARNKROK TO THE
CRACK IN FROM BEAST MODE
HIMSELF.
-- TO THE KRAKEN FROM BEAST MODE
MARSHAWN: CALLE, IF I DIDN'T
PRONOUNCE IT RIGHT, TAP IN WITH
ME AND LET ME KNOW H